you were in Japan a couple of weeks ago
and you posted this picture of you and
your boyfriend and I've and you're both
being held up by sumo wrestler and I
first of all I don't know how this was
this against your will or I don't know
what happened the next thing I knew I
was in a sumos arms I mean that's really
what happened yeah and and and I felt
like the lightest I've ever felt I mean
this man was so strong and he could have
picked me up with just like move well
yes and then Danny went right up - he's
six - you know Danny six - and they
could just pick him up like he's yeah
and I mean he's you know he's lean yeah
but but he's but he's six - yeah do you
like Paul guys is that I do just asking
that's a general question I do
but you know I've never I'm kind of down
for anything that's kind of like
connection is everything right but yeah
I mean I've I've been known to lean more
towards tall what's the tallest guy you
everyone out there I'm just curious
oh man I'm gonna tell I'm so honest I'm
gonna tell this story about this man
okay I dated this guy once who was six
nine he played football six nine yeah he
was six now and was he how heavy huge he
was a linebacker yeah and and and he was
a born again so that kind of threw me
off a little bit cuz you want to get
Christian well yes because you know I
was young so I didn't know if I would be
able to hold out that long
oh he right he didn't right he was like
waiting so he wanted to wait till
marriage no wait til marriage and that
was that that happened so we really only
went out for like one dinner
I was gem birthing at dinner and he was
like so I should tell you this and I it
was like a moment of like I mmm I just
don't think that that's my life's gonna
go yeah but he was great and nice guy he
was and I brought him actually to a
holiday party I mean that's appropriate
to talk about right now yeah we're so
close so close to the holidays right to
this holiday party and I days away and I
remember my mom I remember my mom when I
said I'm bringing this guy that I've
been sort of talking to on the phone and
such like oh cool and I remember when I
said mom this is the guy that you know I
was telling you about and my mom just
was like burst out laughing cuz he was
so huge right right anyway so it didn't
work out but I liked the fact that he
told you during the first date at dinner
and I just picture you excusing yourself
going into the bathroom and climbing out
the window where'd she go you know I
mean hey everybody's got their journey
everyone has their journey yes was out
the bathroom we're to take a break more
with Kate Hudson stick around
you